I said we want to create as much
opportunity for everybody as possible
there's so many jobs that can be created
just in the one Studio alone you're
talking about thousands of thousands of
jobs very high paying jobs so we want to
create as much opportunity for as many
people as possible we want to uncover
new and exciting Talent there's so many
amazing storytellers out there some
amazing stories to be told so for me as
an artist you're trying to encourage as
many people as possible to pursue their
dream if it's a film or television
what movie was it that you that you
filmed in Nevada the first film that I
filmed here was a movie called family
plan for apple and skydance and then we
should be starting filming another film
here uh if things go well in the next
month or so
probably yeah
um what about southern Nevada major fall
weather
uh everything about it I see I don't
know I just feel very much at home here
there's a great sense of community
um you know Wonderful schools great
housing many people that I work with in
many different capacities have all kind
of moved here with us and we're all
thriving and uh just to be welcomed with
open arms I thought you know there are
people welcome me in a very generous way
and I wanted to you know show my
gratitude and appreciation and you know
bring something to the equation as well
so with the first film uh you know we
moved the film from Los Angeles to
Nevada and uh you know I just wish I
made the move soon
very interesting I'm learning a lot uh I
as as an actor as a producer to
filmmaker I've always tried to steer
away from politics but I've learned
quite a bit over the last couple of
months it's been very interesting you
know Jeremy's been wonderful insurance
and some uh some some wonderful advice
with me and you know we want to create
opportunity for everybody
I came here
and hopefully in good faith things will
happen but you know I came here to live
oh I think absolutely especially if you
have a long-term commitment I mean
people have been chasing tax credits
forever from state to state and city to
city and you know those things continue
to change so having a long-term
commitment means you're going to get uh
you know people that come here full-time
for sure